à quel moment vous êtes-vous décidé à
manger de la chair humaine
nous avons eu plusieurs conversations
entre nous et dès que nous avons su que
les livres allaient manquer nous avons
fait une réunion pour débattre du sujet
et nous avons tous été d'accord
[Musique]
montez vidéo jeudi 12 octobre 1972 11
heures du matin dans quelques instants à
bimmother militaire uruguayen va
décoller pour Santiago du Chili durée de
vol prévue deux heures et 30 minutes
[Musique]
à bord ils sont 45 les 16 joueurs de
rugby du plus élégant collège
catholiques de montée vidéo des parents
des supporters et cinq membres
d'équipage lorsque l'avion décolle le
ciel est bleu encore de route premier
avertissement la météo annonce du
mauvais temps le colonel Ferrada qui a
déjà passé 29 fois les hauts sommets de
la cordillère décident de se poser à 22h
en Argentine dernier escale avant le
franchissement du mur des Andes
vendredi 13 octobre c'est la calmi et
l'avion repart par deux fois le pilote
signalera sa position et puis celle-ci
lance
les heures passent l'inquiétude
grandique à la cordillère à une salle
réputation lorsque règne la tempête on
dit que l'avion qui s'y enfonce est
aspirée par les vents et qu'il a peu de
chance de s'en sortir
cette fois il n'y a eu aucun message
aucun indice aucun SOS on ne sait rien
sinon que quelque part derrière ces
sommets ou neige éternel il y a 45
passagers dans un avion qui s'est perdu
corps et bien
alors les recherches s'organisent
Uruguayens chilien argentin participe
aux opérations le 13 octobre 1972
explique un pilote
de secours en montagne nous a appelé
parce qu'un avion uruguayen s'était
perdu dans les Andes
dans le bureau des recherches nous avons
commencé sous les ordres du major Garcia
à établir le plan de sauvetage
pour surveiller l'itinéraire que l'avion
uruguayen devait suivre ce premier jour
en 20
combien d'avions avez-vous utilisé le
premier jour 5 avions je crois pendant
les 10 jours qui ont suivi 25 à 30
environ dans des hélicoptères ont
participé aux recherches
ont donc duré 10 jours oui parce que
c'est le délai limite où l'on estime que
l'on a encore une chance de récupérer
des gens vivants dans un accident de
montagne
comment se fait-il que vous n'ayez pas
repéré l'avion
dans cette région les sommets sont à
plus de 5000 mètres et les avions de
secours devaient voler au-dessus pour
les éviter
blanc cela faisait blanc sur blanc
puisque la couche de neige au sol
atteignait quatre mètres
aucun dispositif d'alarme à bord de
l'épave permettant d'émettre
automatiquement un signal de détresse
car nos hélicoptères sont équipés pour
recevoir de tels signaux
vous avez donc pu survoler les papes
sans la boire sûrement mais nous ne
l'avons pas vu
en Amérique latine l'émotion est intense
car les disparus appartiennent aux
grandes familles d'Uruguay à bord il y a
même les propres neveux du président
alors presse radio télévision ne parle
plus que de ça
[Musique]
dès le premier jour les familles sont
arrivées au Chili bien après que les
recherches officielles aient été
abandonnées elle monte les plus folles
expéditions pour retrouver la trace de
l'avion perdu le ministre d'Uruguay au
Chili fut au centre du drame
je t'ai ami de presque tout se prend mon
fils
office
compagnon de
presque tous ces gens qui sont allés
au même école
les recherches ont duré environ 10 jours
n'est-ce pas je cherche officiel oui
mais pas déjà
cité toujours
à rechercher la viande
qu'il pouvait mais on était certain à ce
moment-là de toute façon même si on
retrouvait l'avion que tout le monde
serait mort mais pas de famille pas le
maire surtout et vous monsieur le
ministre
voici mais oui vous pensez que tout le
monde serait mort cette main parce que
c'est une formation officielle m'a dit
c'est pas possible qui personne
premièrement se porte
d'accident et s'il avait supporté
l'acide il n'y a pas personne qui
pouvait
solliciter dans
la montagne ces conditions
la cordillère garde son secret
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au pied des Andes la vie continue nul ne
change plus à cet avion victime de ce
que les gens du pays appellent la
malédiction des Andes après deux mois de
20 recherches seul le cœur des mers
espère
le messager du destin et c'est humble
berger il a crevé son cheval pour
arriver jusqu'au poste de police de
Puente Negro ce berger est porteur d'une
fantastique nouvelle il a vu deux hommes
qui lui ont remis une lettre
le 20 décembre 1972 vers 9h du soir
Sergio catalan Martinez surveille son
troupeau il est au pied de la cordillère
en un lieu perdu
au-delà du torrent commence la montagne
soudain sur l'autre rive deux hommes
surgissent barbus hirsutent au
comportement étrange il crie vascifer
gesticule mais Martinez ne les comprend
pas demain il reviendra lorsqu'il fera
jour
de l'autre côté du torrent et c'est
pourquoi on ne comprenait rien de ce
qu'il dit c'est il nous faisait des
signes montrant que c'était tombé il se
mettait à genoux s'élever écarter les
bras et à la fin nous savons compris
qu'il venait d'un avion et qu'ils
avaient besoin de secours étiez-vous au
courant de l'accident qui a eu lieu il y
a deux mois oui bien entendu mais comme
on avait déjà tout oublié et qu'ici je
suis un père isolé je ne savais pas
qu'il n'a rien
le lendemain le berger est là avec un
crayon et du papier car il a compris
qu'il se passe à quelque chose le
contact était établi feuille et crayons
lesté d'une pierre sont jetés sur
l'autre rive lorsque le message revient
il lit je viens d'un avion tombé dans
les montagnes je suis uruguayen il y a
dix jours que nous marchons mon ami est
blessé dans l'avion il reste 14
survivants s'il vous plaît aidez-nous
nous n'avons plus de vivre nous sommes
faibles nous ne pouvons plus marcher
j'essayais de revenir les plus vite
possible je changeais ma bulle pour une
meilleure et je suis venu
jetez à 75 ou 80 km
mais ce jour-là je vis beaucoup moins de
temps car je suis venu à toute allure
jusqu'à l'endroit où j'ai trouvé un
camion qui m'a permis d'arriver jusqu'à
pointero
ensuite très simplement accompagné de
ses fils il retournera la cordillère
mais les secours s'organisent c'est à
cheval que les carabiniers iront
chercher les deux rescapés car là où ils
attendent le terrain est inaccessible
les carabiniers mettront 7 heures pour
chercher ramener les deux survivants un
temps record si l'on songe
qu'habituellement ce même trajet se fait
en 20 heures
lorsqu'ils arrivent très Nantes en
couple Fernando parado et Roberto
canessa deux étudiants en médecine le
monde est à l'écoute on fera attendre
les hélicoptères qui doivent aller
secourir les 14 autres naufragés de la
montagne car on tient les deux premiers
miraculés et il faut d'abord qu'il
raconte leur fabuleuse histoire
Roberto canessa qui a perdu sa mère et
sa soeur dans l'accident parle de son
retour vers la Terre des hommes
il leur a fallu 10 jours d'escalade et
de marge forcées avec souvent de la
neige à mi-corps et des températures de
- 25 degrés la nuit pour atteindre le
monde des vivants on les avait choisis
parce qu'ils étaient les plus forts et
de rappeler que 14 hommes sont encore
prisonniers de la montagne faible épuisé
et sans nourriture
précisément la nourriture comment il
fait pour survivre très habilement elles
élu de la question et on ne sur rien de
précis sur leurs conditions de vie
[Musique]
à défaut de rescapés on interroge
alberger peut-être que lui savait
quelque chose de plus mais non il ne
savait rien pauvre infortuné berger
autrefois il vivait tranquille mais
depuis cette aventure on le poursuit
jusque dans la cordillère
qu'est-il arrivé à votre tour à
sainte-fernando j'ai eu la surprise de
me voir dans tous les journaux
vous êtes invité à monter vidéo presque
comme un héros national
oui mon invité mais je ne sais pas si
j'irai
et pourquoi
parce que je suis très occupé cela me
fera grand plaisir de le revoir parce
qu'ils doivent avoir vos coûts changer
depuis quand
mais maintenant je serai très content
[Musique]
leur arrache est venu en dépit du
mauvais temps les hélicoptères repartent
avec à bord l'un des rescapés durant la
terrible descente Paradou à mémoriser
chaque pic chaque crête et lui seul est
capable de désigner au pilote le lieu
exact où j'ai l'avion
et ça met à 5 6000 mètres d'altitude des
turbulences un vol périlleux sous un
Paradou indique c'est là
[Musique]
les pilotes n'ont rien vu mais ils
amorcent la descente le nez presque sur
les pas il l'aperçoivent un faim un bout
de fils large blanc que jamais il
n'aurait pu retrouver
[Musique]
l'accident est simple l'aile droite
heurte un pique à 5000 mètres d'altitude
La Providence voulut que l'avion
désemparée tombe d'une petite hauteur
sur de la neige molle l'atterrissage
l'aile gauche s'est brisée et la
carlingue s'est cassée en deux
l'avant a dégringué une pente à 80
degrés sur 1 km du point d'impact à la
glissade finale la route est jalonnée de
mort
une femme a organisée seule dans la
neige et 4 passagers sont morts de froid
isolés sur un python d'où ils n'ont pu
descendre la queue de l'avion s'est
détachée il y a parcouru encore quatre
kilomètres
[Musique]
finalement dans ce qui restait de la
carlingue il y avait 27 survivants et
cinq morts 13 passagers avaient disparu
à jamais
[Musique]
la capacité des hélicoptères de
sauvetage est en limitée 8 survivants
devront passer une dernière nuit dans
ses décors pour entretenir leur morale
on leur a laissé trois guides
montagnards c'est Sergio Dias qui en
pénétrant dans la cabine désarticulés
aperçu en premier la terrifiant de
vérité seulement il avait donné sa
parole de montagnard de ne rien
révéleri
ce fut dans l'hélicoptère une joint
descriptible nous étions très heureux
nous nous sommes serrés les mains et
chacun de nous avait le visage illuminé
c'était merveilleux
en tant que secouriste volontaire et
pourvu qu'il soit vivant ce n'est pas
toujours le cas
ça a été une rencontre merveilleuse et
très émouvante et je me vois encore
entouré de tous ces jeunes gens qui avec
tant de ferveur me serrer dans leurs
bras m'embrasser d'autres singuliers me
toucher les pieds
[Musique]
après le décollage des hélicoptères nous
nous sommes regroupés à 6 ou 7 mètres de
l'avion
nous n'avions encore rien vu étant resté
éloigné de l'avion car notre première
préoccupation avait été les rescapés
une fois qu'ils se sont assis là je suis
allé chercher le sac qui contenait le
pain
j'ai distribué les sandwichs
ils étaient vraiment très heureux et ils
mangeaient avec une voracité qui faisait
plaisir à voir
que les hélicoptères ne revenaient pas
et après leur avoir préparé une soupe
ils ont commencé à nous montrer
l'endroit où ils avaient vécu
ce qui nous a le plus impressionné ce
n'est pas le fait de voir des cadavres
mais de voir des restes humains nous
avons voulu agir simplement c'est à dire
sans prendre cela au tragique
nous nous sommes comportés comme eux
c'est-à-dire que nous avons adapté notre
comportement au leurre
nous regardions ce qu'il y avait autour
de nous mais nous écoutions surtout
leurs commentaires
nous avons vu l'avion
pratiquement il ne restait que le
fuselage
le pilote et le copilote était dans le
poste de pilotage mais comme à la suite
du choc il avait été complètement écrasé
il était impossible d'en sortir les
corps
[Musique]
des passagers normaux serait mort mais
eux ils étaient jeunes intelligents et
ils ont survécu parce qu'ils ont su
s'organiser dans les premiers jours ils
se sont contentés de soigner les
moribonds de manger ce qu'ils avaient et
d'écouter la radio pour savoir quand on
viendrait les secourir
dès qu'ils ont appris que les recherches
étaient abandonnées touchantes il se
constitue en société sans chef aux lois
un peu spéciales leur seule règle
survivre
ils vont montrer alors un sang-froid et
une détermination rare chacun aura une
mission particulière les débris seront
reconvertis en objets utiles il s'équipe
pour faire des sorties et reconnaître le
terrain
il leur faudra 20 jours pour retrouver
la queue de l'avion récupérer une
batterie et fabriquer de la lumière
les rescapés connaissent aussi des
moments de détente lorsque le soleil
brille ils prennent des mains de soleil
et même des photos
[Musique]
et pourtant il y a eu des heures
dramatiques ainsi le 29 octobre une
avalanche du 9 survivants c'est le
moment précis où il commence à manquer
de vivre fidèle à leur loi ils font
alors quelque chose de terrible il se
lit par impact d’anthropophagie pour
survivre il mangeront les morts deux
exceptions on respectera les femmes et
on évitera qu'un survivant se
nourrissent des restes n'apparant
le pacte conclu l'organisation prévoit
tout les corps inutiles seront conservés
dans la neige comme du surgelés les
corps utilisés sont réchauffés dans la
cabine puis dépecer et hacher à l'aide
d'une lame de rasoir
boulettes de bras et de jambes sont
mangés crus faute de combustible
[Musique]
le retour des rescapés à sainte-fernando
a donné lieu à des scènes inoubliables
la joie la plus pure côtoie le chagrin
réel et profond de ceux qui pleurent
l'une des 29 victimes partout ce ne sont
que rire ou sanglots
[Musique]
le père de Carlos pèse lui n'avait
jamais désespéré il savait que son fils
reviendrait
dans cette étreint tout est exprimé les
longs mois d'angoisse et les terribles
nuits d'insomnie mais le cauchemar est
fini on s'aime on est là et on tombe
enlacé sous le poids d'un amour nouveau
[Musique]
après les parents les médecins un examen
sommaire révèle que ces hommes sont
affaiblis mais en bon état physique
chacun a perdu entre 16 et 30 kilos il y
a quelques cas de scorbuts d'angelures
et de conjonctivite autrement dit rien
de grave mais ce qui frappe tous ceux
qui les approchent c'est leur excitation
les survivants parlent parlent parlent
lié par leur pacte du silence les
rescapés n'ont portant encore rien
révélé mais là sur ce terrain d'aviation
sans avoir rien décelé de précis les
médecins savent que ces hommes
physiquement sains sont des malades et
que dans un avenir plus ou moins
lointain il connaîtront le temps des
angoisses
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre il semble que pour
survivre ces jeunes gens qui avaient un
courage exceptionnel
ont été amenés à prendre des décisions
dont on a beaucoup parlé
notamment on a dit qu'ils avaient mangé
de la chair humaine
bon je crois que vous avez été le
premier à le dire et le reconnaître
ici
même place
nous savons
discuter tous ces avec cette le Père
nous avons pris la résolution
de dire la vérité
et je suis le premier qui aura lieu
j'avais dit pourquoi surtout pourquoi
le fils
le gendre
avait pris sa résolution
les gens on a ratifié ce que j'avais dit
à monter vidéo
mais je suis le premier arrivé à monter
vidéo
le 24 heures
plus terrible de ma vie parce que
personne ne voulait pas me croire
les personnes
à l'hôpital de sainte Fernando les 16
survivants subiront un examen médical
complet
le docteur bachkedano le grand patron de
l'hôpital a examiné les rescapés et
explique les raisons qui les ont incités
à consommer de la chair humaine
je crois que le fait de manger de la
chair humaine et sans aucun doute un
acte extraordinaire ceci dans le cas de
personnes normales peut s'expliquer dans
des situations elle aussi
extraordinaires
et
difficile de juger ce comportement à
froid l'instinct de conservation est un
désastre les plus puissants de la race
humaine
formation
n'a pas été prise facilement elle a été
méditée pesée et prise dans un état de
tension avec une grande clairvoyance et
j'irai même jusqu'à dire avec un grand
sentiment chrétien
qu'une grande compréhension de la part
de leur entourage permettra à ces jeunes
gens de surmonter cette durée preuve et
d'oublier à plus ou moins languette
ne fera que rendre plus difficile
l'oubli d'heures si terrible et si grave
de manger de la chair humaine je crois
que cela est très différent du
cannibalisme je dirais plutôt que ceci
est de l'anthropophagie dicté par les
circonstances
qui sont-ils fils de médecin d'artistes
et de gros propriétaire terriens ils ont
été éduqués dans cette école réputée et
coûteuse tenue par des prêtres irlandais
on leur a donné une seule idée
à la fois la fidélité à leur école et un
esprit d'équipe c'est en jouant au rugby
qu'on les a préparés affronter leur
existence d'hommes leur éducation a été
payante puisqu'à 4000 mètres d'altitude
ils ont su faire face et ne point
paniquer
[Musique]
pour l'heure il profite des vacances
c'est l'été en Amérique du Sud des
vacances pas vraiment ils sont tous sous
contrat pour écrire un livre et faire un
film on leur a déjà versé des sommes
considérables qui iront en principe aux
familles des victimes en apparence ce
que l'on voit ont un équilibre parfait
ni remord ni angoisse
[Musique]
souvenez-vous de connaissa l'homme qui
va chercher du secours étudiante en
médecine il a joué un rôle prépondérant
dans la décision qui a été prise
[Musique]
Carlos pèse étudiant à Grenoble qui a
fêté ses 19 ans perdu dans la cordillère
et à qui ses amis avaient offert un
gâteau de glace et de neige le voilà
dans les bras de son père
[Musique]
et puis Pedro Algora fils de banquier le
plus riche et le plus fêté de la
jeunesse dorée du rugby
[Applaudissements]
je me souviens qu'à un moment donné nous
avons regardé dehors et les montagnes
étaient pratiquement à un ou deux mètres
de nous
puis commencèrent les trous d'air et le
Stewart dit ça y est la danse commence
vous l'ont aussi dire que les choses
devaient des sérieux
[Musique]
qui touchait un rocher on a la viande
plongea s'abattit sur la neige et se
cassa en deux
au passage il accrocha des roches qui
furent des trous dans le fuselage
il y a eu des cris épouvantable et ce
fut une panique effroyable pour ma part
j'ai récité des Ave Maria jusqu'à
l'arrêt de l'avion
comment vous êtes vous organisé
les premiers jours nous avons pu avec
quelques camarades de Me réussites
effectuer de nombreux travaux
des gadgets des corps faisaient des
couvertures et des coussins avec ce qui
restent à des fauteuils
nous faisions de la place pour dormir
plus tard nous avons aménagé des
couchettes avec des matériaux récupérés
sur les pins
nous avons même installé deux lits dans
le couloir juste avant le poste de
pilotage
c'était de bons endroits
et avec le peu de vêtements que nous
portions nous avons dormi
les premiers jours furent très très durs
car il faisait très froid
il y avait des blessés et des moribonds
et nous ne faisions pratiquement rien
car nous attendions les secours
Santiago par radio et que les secours
arrivaient toujours est-il que pendant
la première nuit il niut aucune
organisation tout le monde croyant que
les secours arriveraient bientôt
l'organisation n'a réellement commencé
que lorsque nous avons appris par radio
que les recherches étaient stoppées
c'est-à-dire le 8ème jour au début même
le second jour nous n'avons pas rationné
les vivres étant incapable d'en faire
l'inventaire
de whisky le deuxième jour en voyant
passer deux avions au-dessus de nous
étions à ce moment-là
heureusement pour nous nous avions fait
un Mendo ça provision de chocolat car on
en trouvait pas au Chili et une équipe
de rugby a besoin de sucre
journée
de beau temps car les jours de neige
nous restions à l'intérieur de la cabine
les jours ensoleillés on se levé vers
7h30 on sortait dehors et on fumait une
ou deux cigarettes
puis ils ont écouté la radio la seule
station que nous pouvions capter était
radio et respectables et ainsi nous
avions les informations
Adolphe Strauss fabriquer des lunettes
des chaussures de neige il était
toujours en train d'inventer quelque
chose
entre nous faisaient une croix de 200
mètres sur 200 en piétinant la neige
c'était très pénible car à cette
altitude on manque d'air et d'oxygène
devait être constamment refaite pour
qu'elle ne s'efface pas
[Musique]
officiel et je devais après 7h du soir
fermer toutes les issues et boucher tous
les trous de la cabine
le froid était si fort que j'avais les
mains complètement gelées un jour j'ai
si bien bouché les trous que nous avons
failli tout s'étouffer
de quoi parlez-vous
il y avait différents sujets mais le
thème le plus marquant fut celui de la
nourriture
tout le monde
parlait de nourriture et chacun avait un
plat préféré on s'invitait à déjeuner
les uns chez les autres et nous rêvions
de bons plats dans les grands
restaurants
à quel moment vous êtes-vous décidé à
manger de la chair humaine
et dès que nous avons su que les livres
allaient manquer nous avons fait une
réunion pour débattre du sujet et nous
avons tous été d'accord
il n'avait pas l'habitude mais personne
n'a refusé
[Musique]
je crois que ce sont les étudiants en
médecine qui ont été les premiers à en
faire l'expérience
ou alors
les étudiants en médecine comme vous le
savez sont familiarisés avec les
dissections avec la manipulation des
cadavres
qui donnait à leur accord les premiers
et puis ce fut une question d'habitude
après chacun se servait
tout était devenu naturel
une femme vous a beaucoup aidé par les
modèles
ou alors
nos camarades qui est mort au cours de
l'accident
ce fut une femme vraiment exceptionnelle
tu portais 25 types pendant 15 jours
elle nous a constamment relevé le moral
elle cousait des couvertures et
travaillait de la même façon que nous
cette femme qui a été tuée par la
valanche avait-elle refusé de se nourrir
difficilement
pénibles
il y a pratiquement jamais eu de
dépression
pleurer de tristesse non personne
par contre on pleurait d'émotion en cas
de bonne ou mauvaise nouvelle diffusée
par notre radio
les hélicoptères et puis nous sortions
en courant
personnellement j'ai cru quand j'ai vu
arriver les hélicoptères
[Musique]
vivre dans le silence perdu entre ciel
et glace entouré de mort est une
expérience unique et qui restera unique
70 jours d'une longue et constante
méditation a-t-elle changé le cours de
leur vie
comment ça s'est adopté au moment où
nous sommes en train de parler comment
vous sentez-vous
auparavant nous paraît aujourd'hui
frivole
nous avons appris à donner une valeur
aux choses simples
nous avons appris à apprécier l'eau qui
coule d'un robinet à nous coucher dans
un lit à nous laver les dents
tous ces détails auxquels nous
n'accordions aucune importance ont
aujourd'hui une réelle signification
pour moi voir sortir l'eau d'un robinet
est un miracle car là-bas nous devions
fabriquer notre eau nous avons aussi
appris à tout apprécier c'est pourquoi
j'aimerais adresser un message à tous
ceux qui se droguent à ceux qui ne
vivent que dans le snobisme et l'Afrique
réalité
partez passer trois jours dans la
légende et ainsi vous apprendrez la
valeur réelle de la vie
étrange et passionnante aventure
teintées de mysticisme car tous déclare
qu'ils ont agi selon la volonté de Dieu
l'église d'ailleurs accepté cette
interprétation et leur a donné
l'absolution
le fait d'être sorti vivant de cette
aventure a-t-il pour vous une
signification religieuse les piloques
fut miraculeux par les calculs de
probabilité du point de vue scientifique
nous n'avions aucune chance de nous en
sortir que l'avion soit bientôt tombée
que j'ai survécu à la balance et que
j'ai pu achever mon chemin vers les
secours voilà trois choses qui sont
incroyables quand on ajoute à cela notre
inexpérience en fait aucune
démonstration scientifique ne peut me
convaincre et c'est pourquoi la foi en
Dieu est inévitable à chaque pas nous
pensions je marche et Dieu me guide
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans leur jolie ville la
bordée de piscine il se savent d'aimer
gâtés choyés et approuvés les actes
qu'ils ont commis l'ont été par
nécessité ils étaient en péril de mort
et ils avaient faim l'instinct de survie
les a contraint d'agir ainsi lorsqu'on
est naufragé à 4000 mètres d'altitude
les normes de la société s'écroule et
les problèmes de conscience se posent
différemment
cependant un jour ou l'autre il n'est
pas impossible qu'il craque
[Musique]
d'ailleurs la première faille est là ce
rescapé mentalement malade de quel
remords est-il habité en retrouvant la
liberté il l'a perdu car il va être
hospitalisé
l'histoire est finie finie peut-être pas
car les souvenirs sont comme les vagues
de la mer ça va et ça vient dans 10 ans
dans 15 ans que se passera-t-il parfois
les souvenirs ressurgissent il n'y a que
les morts que l'on enterre
[Musique]